hi in this video I'm going to talk about
numerical aperture and resolution of a
microscope so we don't have a clear-cut
idea about resolution of microscope we
heard we hear a lot of terms like
resolution limit of resolution and
resolving power of a microscope but we
don't have clear idea about what is
resolution of a microscope so for
resolution we need some about idea about
the numerical aperture so here in this
video in the earlier video I have talked
about or what is the numerical aperture
of our lens so numerical aperture of
lens is actually the capability of the
lens to gather light information so it
gathers light in a form of light cone
and for numerical aperture we have
written numerical aperture like a
numerical aperture is mu time signs sine
alpha where alpha is the half angle with
the optical axis so now we have to talk
about what is resolution so here we have
two points and there is a certain
distance between these two points so we
can differentiate easily these are two
different points now if the distance
between these points are this much less
still we can differentiate that these
are two points and now if the different
distance between these are like so small
we can't really differentiate between
the two points so we need to understand
what is the parameter on on which we
should tell these two points a resolved
or these two points are not resolved so
there is a Riley criterion so Riley have
given a criterion on which we can say
two point how these two points are
resolved on not resolved say for instant
the light from this point will go and
this would have a specific intensity
pattern and a same for this point also
light from this point would go and
produce a some intensity pattern let us
draw the intensity distribution and
understand what is the limit of
resolution okay so if you didn't in the
graph we have
intensity on the y-axis and here we are
drawing the intensity profile for the
point a so for the point a the intensity
profile would be like somewhat this so
the major intensity would be in the
central e and the rest of the portion
would be less and for the point B if we
draw another intensity profile like this
and if this thing happened like the
intensity profile of point a and point B
are overlapping
but such that the minima of one
intensity profile is exactly overlapping
with the Maxima that would give us the
result if it comes more closer towards
each other then we cannot really resolve
with each other so let us judge the airy
patterns corresponding to these graphs
so if this is the first order a bright
patch of four this red spot and this is
the blue spot for instance so if this
kind of scenario happens so we can just
tell it these two spots are just
resolved so this distance between them
are just resolved so the limit of
resolution D we denote it as d it is
limit of resolution Lucien is actually
defined as like a constant or a constant
a constant times lambda divided by
numerical aperture of the microscope or
we can write it as lambda by mu sine
alpha where mu is the refractive index
of the medium so from this equation we
can say that if our lambda it's big
then this distance is quite big and we
don't need that we need this D to be
very small if the D is very small then
we are able our microscope is able to
differentiate between two very closely
related spots so for how we can increase
how we can increase how to increase the
resolving power
but we can do we can decrease lambda we
can decrease lambda so if we decrease
lambda as d is directly proportional to
lambda so lambda D would be also
decreasing if we increase the mean that
means the refractive index of the media
we can get higher resolution that is why
the microscope for oil immersion lens we
use oil where for oil immersion or oil
immersion lens mu is greater than mu is
greater than 1 and also we can make
changes in this alpha you can make
changes in the Alpha to increase our
limit of resolution so our resolving
power of a microscope resolving power of
a microscope is inversely proportional
to this limit of resolution so the
microscope which have very low limit of
R is limit of resolution the resulting
power of that microscope would be huge
would be high in contrast a microscope
which has a big limit of resolution its
resolving power would be low so what is
the general resolving power and what is
the general smallest distance what is
actually what is a realistic value of D
what is the realistic value of D so it
appears to get this criterion fulfilled
we should have D equal to a length which
is half the wavelength of light we are
using so for instance if we are using a
400 nanometer light with a wavelength
400 nanometer then our D could be
theoretically 200 nanometer but not more
than too hot not below 200 mile our D
could be like 300 our D could be like
220 but our D can't be below 200 so that
is actually the diffraction limit beyond
which we cannot differentiate between
two spots so this is all about the
numerical aperture resolution and how
these two things are related hope you
liked it you enjoyed it please like and
subscribe